are you looking for a game that will
make you feel smart and pretty well look
no further
introducing the Justin Bieber our gay
explorer 14 fun worlds and collect
power-ups that make Justin Bieber
stronger like the glitter puppy the
cupcake the dildo unicorn but don't
touch those yucky cooties and kill the
evil puberty's if they touch you you'll
turn into a man oh no as you progress
through the game you can add new friends
to your party like Nick Jonas but be
careful because Nick has diabetes and
you are ruling sweet there's even a
super surprise boss at the end it's uh
sure your fame has surpassed my own and
for that you must die also your initials
backwards are BJ so what are you waiting
for pre-order your copy of Justin Bieber
are gay today from Game slop and get a
free copy of Kasia rock band rated p FR
th burg but alright sorry I was emailing
my mom happy fate trailer Tuesday
everybody I hope you like the trailer
you just saw and I hope you're not
disappointed to know that it's fake and
that the Bieber games probably never
gonna really be made but it's okay is if
you have any ideas for game trailers you
would like to see that you think would
never be made I'll make up leave your
ideas in the comments or leave them on
our Facebook page and I'll try to make
it by Tuesday if I like your idea thanks
a lot guys and you know be sure to
subscribe and all that kind of stuff
[Music]